thanks everyone for coming to pi data
global 21 20 21 oh
and thanks for coming to james powell's
live q a and be be a pandas expert
and i will uh i'll just go ahead and not
hand it off to james
thank you for that scott good morning
everybody and welcome to a follow-up
session to my pi data global talk i am
of course james powell for those of you
who haven't had a chance to meet me in
person
i serve as the chair of the num focus
board of directors and also the vice
president of pi data but beyond that i
also dabble a little bit in tools like
numpy pandas
broader python technologies and i've
been to a lot of these events and given
quite a few talks
the question of how to be a pandas
expert
can either be answered in one minute
maybe less maybe 15 seconds in one
sentence which is learn how indexing and
index alignment works or in two and a
half to three hours by really
understanding what i mean by indexing an
indexing alignment and so i apologize
that when i was faced with the
dilemma of whether i give a one minute
talk which is just me saying the word
index over and over and over for one
minute or whether i give a two and a
half hour talk which is me saying the
word index over and over and over and
over with some live coding behind it i
opted for the latter which is why we
pre-recorded the tutorial just to give
you an opportunity to absorb all of that
material
now i don't anticipate that all of you
or even that many of you probably had a
chance to watch that
but
what we can do in this session if you
don't have specific questions is i've
prepared another maybe two three four
hours worth of examples of which we'll
try and cover as many of them as we can
that touch upon all of the ideas that
are covered in that tutorial and so you
can see these in practice and then maybe
if there's something interesting there
or some ideas that you find might be
worth following up on you might go back
to the video and take a chance to look
at it but
before we jump into any of that i do
want to see from the audience i want to
open up for any q a and see if there are
any specific questions that arose during
the talk
and
there was there is one question about
what the tea that i'm sipping it's the
same tea that i drink every morning i
have
some tea that i got from the uk some
nice earl grey tea in the morning
for an afternoon talk i would be
drinking maybe a nice green tea or
something like that but
having answered that one question about
rt
i want to open up for any other
questions maybe related to
pandas indexing numpy x-ray
i think the talk ended up touching upon
quite a few things and towards the end
uh
i basically went through about what 80
of all the methods you have on a pandas
dataframe and showed how every single
one of them can be
maybe it's not something that directly
operates on the index but it's something
that's either index aligned or something
that has some consequential aspect of it
related to the index it's just probably
the most dominating and most interesting
thing about pandas
but it doesn't seem like we have that
many questions oh do the context of
index alignment apply to das as well
um
this is much harder to say i think the
das data frame is an attempt to
mimic the api of pandas
in order to
[Music]
in order to pro present a
computationally similar environment with
different execution but one of the
things about the index is the index if
it's a mechanism is fairly difficult for
you to serialize and it's a fairly
difficult thing for you to distribute
without a lot of additional
mechanism behind it and so while i'm not
a das expert although it's one of my
goals for next year to become a desk
expert i suspect that there are some
significant distinctions between how das
candles the index and the panels i wish
i could answer that a little bit more
authoritatively but that's about the
best i can do for you for now
in the pivot table operation in pandas
what's the difference between the index
and the group by parameter
the index parameter is going to set what
the index is and the group by parameter
is going to
oh that's interesting
these are small details my my gut
feeling would be that the
you know when you look at a pivot table
operation it's basically equivalent to a
group by unstack
uh and so i suspect i don't know we have
to look at the we'll have to look at the
api we have to look at the api to answer
that so let's jump into the other
material that i have and let's take a
look at the documentation and see if we
can answer that question and so in just
a moment i'll share my screen with you
behind me you'll see my screen i'll hide
in the corner here and you can see i
have a little bit of follow-up material
i want to answer this question about the
group by parameter part of what the
point i wanted to make regarding being a
pandas expert is
it is generally not the case that
expertise of these tools requires
memorizing the api and knowing all the
names of the keyword arguments knowing
all the different modes that you have
because these things change and they
change very quickly and they change over
time and nobody can keep up
and as a consequence what i think you
need to do if you want to develop
expertise is understand the core ideas
the core concepts and once you have an
understanding of those core ideas and
those core concepts then
most of the time you can look at
something that you haven't seen before
in the api and you can kind of make make
sense of it
building upon a framework that you have
and so as an example if we were to go to
pandas.pydata.org
and look at our
operation for pivot table
we'll see there's apparently a group by
argument here
is there
oh oh oh oh i see it's not a group by
keyword argument you're asking about
it's the group by operation and the
pivot table oh
well the difference here is the group by
operation is going to preserve the same
column index and so it's just going to
operate on groups defined by the row
index whereas a pivot table can both
change the row index and the column
index and so you can see here i don't
have an exhaustive understanding of or
an exhaustive knowledge of all the
different keyword arguments on these
different methods that you have in
pandas and so through me a little bit
what would they group by mean because
presumably you know that would be
handled by that index parameter but i
think the question instead was actually
what is the difference between these two
different operations and largely they do
something very similar it's just that in
the case of the
group by operation you keep the same
columns but with that said let me show
you one or two very quick examples
i'll live code these for you for cases
where you might have an intuition to use
pure python or you might have an
intuition to use numpy but this idea of
index alignment can be used effectively
to answer real questions in a terser
less mechanical more direct fashion
the first is an example pulled from some
data sets
or some synthetic data sets for modeling
a problem that i was working on which
was you have a series of actions that
are performed on some entities
and you need to make sure that those
actions performed on those entities are
consistent
and most of it is moving things in and
out of some sort of till or some sort of
book so the idea would be that you have
you know a bunch of data sources like
five files that correspond to this
information on five distinct entities
and for each of these entities if you
look at one of these files
it's just a sequence of just as a
simulation
of the idea this is just a sequence of
numerical values that have moved and so
this is just taking that same general
idea and saying oh you know this is like
a till and you're moving money in and
out of this till like 25 cents is a
quarter five the five dollar bill one
would be a one dollar bill
and what you want to make sure is that
at every point in time this till is
consistent if you had five one dollar
bills or five one euro notes you
couldn't at some later point give away
six of those because then you'd go
negative and so it's trying to figure
out how do we make these things
consistent and when you look at this
data the data itself is actually
relatively easy to parse and to load you
know this is basically numpy load text
data
and so
nothing really stops us
from saying you know what
these are just our transactions
loaded from this file
and
taking a look at
these transactions
and saying you know what numpy and dra
i'm done i don't need anything more and
then maybe i'll do some sort of looping
over this numpy and the array or maybe
some sort of operations that's done by
dra but what you can see is what pandas
adds on top of your simple numpy-like
structures or simple you know
one-dimensional structures is the
ability to have the index the index
being some sort of metadata that has
well-defined semantics in terms of data
operations and that then allows you to
perform
human meaningful operations on this data
and so what i would do instead of
you know solving a problem like this in
pure numpy where i'm trying to say okay
if you got a hundred dollar bill at the
beginning of the day and then you got
two twenty dollar bills and then you
gave away three twenty dollar bills and
a 100 bill
you should end up with negative 120
bills that's inconsistent and no 100
bills i'm trying to track those things
and if you think about it actually this
is a fairly straightforward problem to
solve in pandas
we'd start by modeling these
transactions as a series
and this is the case where we can
immediately talk about how
this data may look
like
or rather when we use pandas it may look
like the index is something that we care
about when we're talking about the and
let's just make comment this sucks i
don't need this print to the screen
it may look like it's just the the row
index and you know i often complain
about these things here that you see
these range indices but this range index
is actually correct for this data this
range index corresponds to this
numbering from 0 to 300 corresponds to
the number of the transaction that we
happen to be looking at at some point in
time so the zeroth transaction the first
transaction the second transaction the
third transaction and so forth and so on
so for the indexing that we want to do
it is not on the rows the index thing we
want to do is actually going to be on
the columns
in fact what we probably want to do with
this data is we want to pivot it and if
you think about these operations that
you can perform on a pandas data frame
like melt and pivot and stack and
unstack largely they are operations that
are about moving either things from the
data portion into the column index into
the row index from the row index into
the column index or vice versa and so a
pivot operation very straightforward
it's a dual of the melt operation where
the melt operation moves something from
the column index down into the data
portion a pivot can move something from
the data portion up into the column
index
and so if i were to do this what i would
probably want to do is set
my index actually set my columns
to
this one
transaction operation so let's do this
and let's actually
let me do this a little bit differently
just to make this easier with the pivot
because i can't pivot on a series and
series doesn't have any columns but i
can pivot on data frame here and i can
make this a data frame carrying two
pieces of information that i want where
the first piece of information is the
actual transaction
and the second piece of information is
the denomination
right and this would just be the
absolute value of the transactions and
once i have that then
the way to solve a problem like this is
fairly straightforward because
oops
this is let's just do apps like this
there we go
and
we can manage to spell everything
correctly this morning what i want to do
is i want to take
these values in the denomination column
and i want to pivot them up into the
column index so here
uh denomination
like that
and here you can see now what i've
created is a data frame that represents
oh you've got a hundred dollar bill 100
bill 100 bill and it's now pivoted these
operations correctly and then what i can
do from here is fill in a bunch of zeros
for every time where nothing happened
i can take this
result
and i can divide it
by the value of its columns
so this gives me a basically a one or a
negative one oops
so that's good that's good
and let's double check one thing here
okay very good
and so here i want to take
i have the transaction denomination oops
i wanted this to be
the other
that's correct that's the transaction
number that's the domination
uh yes that should be very good so i
should be able to divide this thing by
its columns
and let's take a look what the columns
actually are
and so there we go oh yeah and i want to
okay and so here i also want to do let
me set the index here let me set the
i think i want to set the values here
and set the values to what the
transaction is
there we go
and so here you can see this is actually
what i wanted i wanted the values of
these things to be the transaction there
we go and then i can pipe this
and divide this by its columns
values and so now i get 0 0 or sorry 0 1
or negative 1 values depending on
whether you know this thing changed
hands or not whether this thing you know
whether you got one of these or didn't
get one of these and turn these all into
integer values and then you know the
answer for whether this is consistent is
do a cumulative sun or expanding sum and
then it'll sum things up and so you can
see at the end of this day you know you
had 80 of these 89 of these 20 26 of
these and 20 of these to see if this is
ever inconsistent you look for anything
where this is less than zero
so you do something like less than zero
and then do you know any any on this to
see if you know you ever gave away more
than you had and so forth and so on and
i'm doing this on just one data set if
you want to do this on all the data sets
what you do so you do this exact same
operation except this
this part here would be the inner level
of a multi-index and the outer level of
that multi-index would be
the actual entity that you're looking at
and you do this within a group by
operation so you just set this up and
then do a group by and then another
rolling operation within it this is a
very common pattern that you see in one
of the later examples i can show you how
you can do group eyes with
with
you know expanding and rollings within
them
and so
one question about when you use pandas
and when you spark is a ver it's a very
good question
and
in
the case of you know pandas versus spark
i think the major difference is does
your data fit into memory and does your
data have complex indexing one of the
nice things about the pandas index is
because it is written in pure python
code it's a pure python mechanism it's
possible that you can write very complex
mechanical indices that really are only
are well defined in terms of you know
python code that you have in front of
them and so
i would say that
in terms of pandas versus spark the core
reason for pandas would be well if i can
fit everything into into memory at once
it's fine
and if it's the case that
you know i have some very complex index
like an interval index or whatnot i
don't know if you can do the similar in
spark
now i want to push on to the next
example which is a little bit
a little bit
harder than the previous example but
maybe a little bit more interesting
this is an example that i needed to do
or this is actually an analysis i used
to do fairly recently
which was i was going online and i was
looking at hard drive prices because
generate a lot of video content and when
you generate a lot of video content you
generate a lot of files and because
there's a lot of data you need to store
it somehow and so the question was well
which hard drive should i buy of all of
these choices that i found online
and
the
problem with
this question is
naively what you might say is you might
say what's the price per gigabyte or the
price per terabyte and so here you can
see this is clearly some sort of csv
like data or tab separated data with a
manufacturer the size of the drive and
its cost
and you might say i'll just divide the
size of the drive by its cost or vice
versa and optimize for that when you do
that you're actually going to find that
the stuff that they don't want to
sell anymore that don't want to keep an
inventory anymore it's very cheap and
it's the stuff that you don't really
want to buy because if you buy a four
terabyte drive
you know great you're just gonna have to
buy another one in two days time or
another one in three days time and so
it's actually not the best purchase to
make because from an operational
perspective you're just going to be
stacking up you know your your power
requirements and your your uh
you know requirements for you know
containers for these drives instead what
you might want to do is you might want
to perform an analysis looks like this
given the average prices per drive
how much loss is there if i purchase any
of the other ones at
their actual price and so for example if
i can buy something for a dollar a
terabyte
and then i purchase something that's 12
terabytes for
a dollar fifty a terabyte how much do i
actually lose and i actually lose like
what six dollars there and so is that
survivable and so what you probably want
to do is set a threshold and say i'm
willing to overpay up to say 50 bucks or
80 bucks if it means i can buy
less physical hardware and so it's a
little bit more complex of analysis and
it's a very easy analysis to do in
pandas and so what we'll do is we'll
take this raw data
we'll read this in
using read csv
and so
we'll do a csv of our data
the separator for this data is
just the regular expression separator
any any number of sequential spaces and
let's do this and let's print this out
as we go
and
uh there's no header on this
and what else do we have there's
let's title the columns that'll make our
life easier
and what are the columns the columns are
the manufacturer the size and the price
and
you know if we're here to talk about the
index then we better set an index on
this thing so what we'll do is we'll set
the index and the very reasonable thing
the way i'm going to look up this data
the way i'm going to categorize this
data is by manufacturer and size
and we'll start on index not a bad idea
to just sort on the index because any
group by operation will be able to see
the indexes sorted pandas indices know
that they are in sorted order they know
they're monotonic and so
group by operations don't have to do
redundant sortings if they're performed
on the index and index is already sorted
so if i'm doing a bunch of work on this
data frame you know that might be useful
so i get something looks like this this
is not actually
uh actually we'll keep this as a data
frame although i could squeeze this into
a particular i could squeeze this into a
single series
but i'll leave it as a data frame for
now
what i can think about is here for my
analysis
i can actually unstack
you know by stack and unstack operations
give me the ability
to take things that are in this row
index and put it into the column index
so an unstack on the manufacturer just
pulls that that level
up like that but what i actually want to
do here is i want to do something akin
to like a cartesian product what i want
to do is i want to take
every
every price against every price
or i want to take every relative price
against every relative price map them
out so i want to say what's the price
for the four terabyte item
given
the or what's the price for the 12
terabyte item given the unit pricing of
the four terabyte item and this ends up
being fairly straightforward to do what
i'll do is i'll take a mesh grid
of the prices divided by their index you
can see because the indexing here
is set up
the way it is and let's uh let's do one
thing
we're going to get meshgrid from numpy
and here just for the purposes of our
analysis let's just look at one
manufacturer and then we can generalize
this to all of them
but usually that just means some sort of
group by operation and so just to keep
our lives easier we'll do this and we'll
actually squeeze this into a series or
we could have done you know a squeeze
equals true here
if we wanted to
but
here you can see if we perform and let's
do this
and
let's also get what we want mesh grid
here
there we go here you can see we have the
original prices
if we divide them by their own index
then we get the per unit pricing if we
take that and we do a mesh grid on it
we get all the ways you can repeat this
we get the tiling and the repeating of
this thing and if we mesh grid it with
its own index
then what we get is all the ways that
you can repeat one of these against the
other and the other one against the
first and so we get the ability to say
okay this is the per-unit pricing of one
of them against the four against the
four against the four against the or
sorry against the four the six the eight
the ten the twelve and the fourteen
what's the per unit price and the other
one against all of these and so mesh
grid is just you know this idea of
tiling one or repeating the other so you
can do
everything against everything else
comparisons and this shows up in the
talk when i show you you know if you
wanted to compare every single value in
a numpy and d array against every other
value in a numpy and d array
that would just be an eq on the mesh
grid of the nd array against itself and
so here this is a fairly common thing
that comes up anytime you want to say oh
can compare everything in this structure
against every other thing in this
structure perform that cartesian product
and so what i'm going to do is i'll just
multiply these
pass these as two arguments to numpy to
multiply them
and there we go
and one unfortunate thing is this is
going to give me the structure in the
wrong order i kind of want to say given
that you purchased this thing give me
this thing the mesquite's going to be
transposed so or the multiply is going
to result in this being transposed and
so here we go i'm going to put this back
into a data frame
one of the things that i find can
really
indicate that you've gotten very
comfortable with pandas
is when you know exactly when you want
to drop down into numpy
and when you want to do the operations
at the pure numpy level and when you
want to do them at the pure pandas level
and it's not just oh i can't figure out
how to do this here i'll just get the
dot values and figure out how to do it
there but it's quite judicious and this
is a case where you definitely want to
do this because there's no equivalent of
pandas meshgrid because that's not
really an index related operation
multiply this is just so that i can save
myself you know having to assign these
to two variable names and so here
it really is the mesh grid that kind of
forces me to do the numeric operation on
the raw numerical data
in numpy or at least in the numpy api i
should say and then pull it back into
the pandas api but what you can see here
is
this is the original
four terabyte at the four terabyte unit
price this is the six terabyte at the
four terabyte unit price this is the
eight terabyte at the four terabyte unit
price and so on so if i take that result
and i subtract it from the actual prices
i'll get the the overage that i'm paying
but if i have a data frame i always want
to set up the index and the columns
correctly and so here i'll just grab
whatever the original index was here and
because i want to do this as a cartesian
product but the index and the columns or
whatever the original pricing was
and so
let's do this
and so here you can see it very clearly
what we have
is
if i purchased
the four terabyte at the 10 terabyte
unit price if i purchase the 12 terabyte
at the 10 terabyte unit price is what we
get and if we subtract from this
the actual original prices
then
we get how much we're being ripped off
and so you can see if you bought the 18
terabyte at the 18 terabyte unit price
you're not being ripped off at all
because you're buying the same thing at
its own unit price but what you can do
is you can look down these columns and
say oh you know what if i
take a look at this data and let's round
this data because it makes our life a
lot easier to look at this i don't
really care about how many cents i've
lost
if i take this and then i maximize or
minimize down this axis i can see what's
the worst i could do and so what i'll do
is i'll minimize
down the
and i'll minimize removing
the index
and so here you can see this is the
worst amount of money i could possibly
lose comparatively
based on
what the cheapest actually is and this
is a much better analysis and so in the
end i ended up buying the 18 terabyte
drive because i thought 80 bucks but i
don't have to worry about this for a
couple of months okay maybe that's worth
it and so there you go and you can see
these are all
a little bit of index operations and
judicious no knowledge of where pandas
really fits into my story
now let me take a look at any questions
and
let me show you the next thing
the next thing is the star trader
example and the star trader example is
an example of
the power of index aligned operations
and how you can use it to answer
questions really really easily in a very
fluent fashion if you are aware of the
index and if you're not aware of the
index where things are just going to be
you know manual loops extremely clumsy
manual loops and so
star trader was a game from the
70s
where you kind of travel between
different locations and you sell
different things to you know different
people it's one of those arbitrage games
you may have played one of these on a
calculator back in the day um there's
another one called drug wars but here
this is star trader this is the
beginning of them and so you can travel
between these locations and you can sell
these different items and in order to
model the star trader game what i'm
going to do
is i'm going to model the market
i'm going to model the market as a data
frame
and the data frame is going to say at
this particular location the cost of
such and such item is such and such and
so that'll model what all the different
prices are
and then i'll model my own inventory and
i'll see how to price my inventory
against the market and then i'll see how
to how i might build a you know
strategy for
analyzing where do i move where do i
travel to in order to make the most
profit and then what do i purchase there
and things like that
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to generate this as random data so here
we'll use our default
or
default rng
like that
and what we'll do is we'll initialize
this as something where the column names
are each individual asset
and actually i don't want to include the
credits because the credits are your
cash money so what i'll do is i'll do
this
i'll distinguish between the tradable
assets and the
and the assets that are not tradable
so
here we go
so here we'll have each column be each
one of these tradable assets and each
one of these will be a panda series
with some random data and the size of
this
is just going to be
the
we'll say
we'll pick two places where you can sell
this thing
up to we'll pick between two and
one more than half of the places where
this can be sold so i'm going to create
a random
set of numerical values and i'll say
okay maybe
some particular item like metals or
uranium or software can be traded
anywhere from two to say however many
total locations are divided by half and
so that means that not everything is
saleable everywhere
and so that gives me that and i'm going
to these are just random values so let's
multiply these times something larger
and we'll round them as well and i'm
going to need this later
so let's capture this for a moment
and i'll index this series on
how many stars that i want to pick well
like this
and so here what i'll end up with is i
should end up with something
that looks like
if i get all my imports right
i should end up with something that
looks like this and let's see that
should be nuts let's make this stars so
you try you travel between the stars in
this game
and let's see there we go and so here
you can see
at each location in the universe
you know this is what everything is
worth or this is what everything can be
bought for and the nan
is meaningful here because it represents
that you can't buy or sell that thing at
that particular location let's round
this to decimal points just to make it
easier to read and let's just do
something really simple here let's add
in
the untradable asset the credits and
let's just set that to one
and so that means that
you know a dollar is worth a dollar no
matter where you go
so you can see a dollar worth a dollar
no matter where you go but these
different things have different prices
in different locations and some things
are not tradable in some locations now
one thing that you find you do fairly
often
when you are
really thinking about index alignment is
you want to tell pandas how to perform
the index alignment especially on things
that might be multi-indices so you want
to give your indices names
and this is how pandas will identify oh
these are these are actually the same
index if there's a multi index these are
the same levels let me do the alignment
there one unfortunate thing about pandas
is the naming
of one of these indices it kind of
prints in this ugly fashion
but you know i could i could have done
the string here but i actually like to
use the raw python object
just to wrap this up
my inventory is actually fairly easily
simulate because here this is just a
panda series would say anywhere from 10
to say a thousand
of
each one of the tradable assets
and
we'll just set the index on this thing
to
the tradable assets
like that
and
we'll just say in addition to that you
start off your life with a hundred
dollars as well or maybe a thousand
dollars
and let's sort on this index here
and let's sort on this index here might
as well
and
the biggest thing that would probably
help us in our code is to learn to
become a spelling expert
because
turns out that
that is my greatest problem oh and
because i'm using these enums here i
have to uh
it's one unfortunate tiny thing i have
to do i have to do this
these things aren't sortable
so
i'll do this
we'll make this an ordered enum
and you can see you know the name of the
game is to go as fast as we possibly can
self.value less than other value
and then the eq is pretty much the same
thing
except equivalent and so this will allow
us to do
a couple of useful things like you know
grouping this thing if they're sorted
and let's make these
order enums
so we can use some pure python together
with this
and oh we need to make these hashable
too
there we go so here we have the market
doesn't print out that nicely and here
we have our inventory and the beautiful
thing about this index alignment idea is
here's what i actually have at the
beginning of the game i have a thousand
credits 270 star gems 899 units of
uranium
the total value of my inventory
is the market times the inventory
and this isn't the total
value of my inventory
this is the total value of my inventory
at one location this is the total value
of inventory simultaneously at every
location in the galaxy at once let me
remove the naming here because it's just
actually i'll show you a little trick
that you can do here
uh
here this is gonna be a little actually
i'll just make this a string
it really sucks into this value
intermediation but it's very difficult
to remove that one part of it but you
can see here this is the value of
everything simultaneously in the
universe at once and so i could express
this as a sum
to figure out what the summed
value of this is at every possible place
in the universe simultaneously here by
default it's summing removing the row
index and leaving just the ascii so you
know the total this should actually be
mean
for this to be meaningful so the average
value of my uranium is that the average
value of my metals is that or i can do a
sum
on the
removing the columns and here is the
total amount of money i have at all
points and so what you could think is if
i wanted to figure out how to do a
strategy here i would just do this and
then say
what's the index max what's the location
i should go to i would travel to that
location ivan is where i can make the
most money i'd go to ivan and then sell
everything and
you know i could compute what i'm able
to sell pretty easily because what i'm
able to sell at ivan is just
the market
at
that location
dropping the nands
and so that's these are these are the
prices and these are things i can sell
if i want to figure out what the actual
items i want to sell it's just the index
of that so these are things that i can
sell and so
if i wanted to you know figure out what
would happen if i moved there i would
just say take this
divide it by that
and we'll drop the
nands afterwards
and
let's check one thing
let's see what this gives us
oh the
inventory is on
let's see what this gives us for a
second these should be index aligned but
there may be a
and that's good
and our inventory
is good
it's there
and so we should be able to do an index
lined division here
just have to figure out why we get uh
these obscure errors most of these times
these obscures are just some sort of
index alignment issue and so
here in this case it's probably just the
case that i'm performing something
there's something in here that's coming
out or what i can do is i can pull out
those nands first
let's see
i multiplied this gives me what the
price of my inventory is and so
uh could just be my order genome
so we'll just fix this very slightly
this is a little bit too sophisticated
with the ordered enum
but
here we go
there we go
and so our index alignment should work
again
the biggest problem in our life is
really not the pandas index is the
spelling and so you can see the index
alignment actually worked the way we
expected it to there's just some small
mechanics with these in with this enum
type and what you can think is you know
this is how many of each of these things
that i would sell and what i'd probably
do is i'd probably do a
dot lock on this
to remove the credits and so what i'd
probably do is i'd probably do a lock
with the lambda
take the columns or the take the index
that this has
and
do an index difference removing
assets credits so i don't try and sell
my money for the value of my money which
is meaningless and by the way this has
to be a collection of some sort
and so here these are all the this is
the this is the number of each of the
entities that i would sell you know for
some
amount and so i guess
sorry this would be
this would be the amount of profit that
i make by selling all of the particular
items and so here you can see this is
the profit i would make and if i sum
that dropping the nands and whatnot you
know we get to what we want to get to
but the general idea here is by having
these
these data frames and these series in
this index aligned fashion we can
perform these operations just one simple
line of code just saying inventory times
market value obviously a little bit of
mechanics if i'm doing something fancy
where the actual index values are these
enum types usually you know you're
dealing with things that are strings and
so everything's already built out for
you in this particular case i had to
make them sortable i had to make them
you know comparable in some fashion and
you can think why that would be is
because what's happening down the line
is pandas is trying to figure out how to
match these up so it's comparing them
against each other and that previous
error was coming up because trying to
compare one of these things against a
nun value at some point part of the
calculation is trying to say oh wait is
this
index you know correct with this this
particular or is this matching up with
this thing so i just have to make sure
that these are comparable in a
reasonable fashion but if they are the
pandas will do all of my index alignment
for me
a much more sophisticated version of
this problem is the trading example
the fourth example
where i go to the data
that i shared with you in the talk
and
we have
some data corresponding to some trades
that were done
on
some
uh tickers at some point in time
and
what we want to figure out is what is
our position and what is the value of
our position uh what's the average buy
price what's the average sell price you
know how much of this do we have
and if we want to make this more
sophisticated we can even take into
account that there may be some taxes or
fees associated with these and we can
make use of some of the more
sophisticated indexing mechanisms and
pandas namely things like the interval
index to say if the trade was anywhere
between 0 and 10 000 units this is the
tax that is applied to it
if the number of trades i think for the
fees if you do is between 0 and five
trades a day this is the uh fee that's
associated if you do between if you do
over 15 this is the broker fee that's
associated so we could in pandas not a
whole lot of code compute things like
what is my position and what would my
corresponding broker fees be and these
interval indices are beautiful because
you can just say oh give me you know i
did three trades what's the fee and it
will tell you fee is 0.15 because it's
within this particular interval
and so you can see here that some of the
other mechan some of the other libraries
that you might use that support a data
frame like api
well they're doing that in order to
mimic what you're comfortable with
from a analytical perspective but it's
fairly difficult to mimic the power of
all of these arbitrary indices that you
can use in part because many of them are
based on you know software mechanics
that may not be distributable or may not
be serializable in one fashion or
another
i don't think in general the panda's
index is serializable it's just that the
common ones happen to be
but
you know it's really more of a mechanism
for identifying how to go from a human
description of the data to the physical
description of the data and how to line
things up and match things up and what
is considered to be equivalent to what
else and in the previous example
i was using just a regular pandas index
just a regular object index but i was
using with custom data and you can see
the trick there was to make sure those
enum types were probably or were
correctly
comparable to each other so that the
index line would work but for this
example we want to do something a little
bit fancier
and so the starting point of this
example would be you know let's try and
figure out what our position is how much
do we actually hold having done these
traits
and so you can see for a particular
ticker you know feci you know we traded
13 500 and then we want to see not only
what's our total holding but when do we
cross through the zero axis so when does
it go from a long position to a short
position and vice versa to figure out
the total holding that's actually quite
easy
with this we just group by the ticker
and then
just sum
right and so here this gives you
something that is indexed on whatever
this group by operation is and so here
you can see for each one of our tickers
that's what our sum of we probably want
to sum the volume because the price
doesn't really
price doesn't really
make sense to sum if we wanted to figure
out what our average price was we could
take the mean of the price
that's fine
but part of what i want to show you in
this example is one look how lucky i am
that i've generated random data with
four letter tickers
and nothing came up inappropriate
we're already on the right track and two
i want to show you a little bit about
the group by api and how you can think
about that group api via understanding
of the index because there's like a
group i ag a group i apply a group by
transform there's all of these different
operations that you can perform what's
the difference well understand that the
group by ag and the group by transform
operate on a per column basis they
operate on one column at a time or
basically they operate on a
one-dimensional structure at a time in
the talk i make an argument for ypan
this is really only one-dimensional data
a data frame is not two-dimensional and
i'll let you review why i'm so confident
about that or at least the argument that
i make but whatever the case is if
you're doing a group by down the rows or
down the columns you can only look at
one of those entities of time you're
only a one-dimensional structure at a
time with a plot with ag and transform
with apply all bets are often do
whatever you want
as a consequence you can immediately see
that certain things are not possible to
compute directly with
ag or transform namely a weighted price
if you were to weight the price by the
sorry a weighted average price you were
to weight the price by the volume
you need two columns you can't do that
in a simple group but you have to do a
group i apply or
you have to do some sort of contortion
which gives you intermediate steps and
you may have heard people say
that
never dot apply apply is so slow
they're right but they're usually right
for the wrong reason
there are two dot applies that you have
to watch out for in pandas the first one
is dot apply on a series object on like
a or on a data frame object
and this is where you operate some
python function some python user defined
function
on the scope of every row
of a pandas data frame maybe every
column of a pandas data frame actually
that's not really worth worrying about
too much but
apply if you're just doing it down the
row axis you're applying it on every
single row python function every single
row or on a series on every value in
that series and the reason for that is
your data frames are big got thousands
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
millions of rows or more
your series are very big the whole
reason you're using numpy pandas x-ray
any of these tools is for this idea of a
restricted computation domain so you can
leave the restrictions of the python
universe dynamic dispatch the things are
all boxed that you know you have
arbitrary promotion of integers things
like that
and
because python function calls are very
slow it's about seven c stack frames at
least historically that's about what
it's been just invoke a python function
they are currently working on making
that faster but just a python function
call all by itself is relatively slow
and if you're doing one function call
per row of your data and your data is
structured so it's got a lot of rows
because it's big data then it's going to
be slow that's why you avoid
dataframe.apply that's why you avoid
series.apply but that's not why you
avoid group by apply
because
what group i apply does
is it breaks
your data frame into groups based off of
the grouping criteria
and then it applies the user defined
function on each group
usually it's going to be the case
a preponderance of the number of times
that the number of groups is
significantly smaller than the total
number of rows
because if you had 10 million rows and
you had 9 million groups
you're kind of kind of thinking what is
the group by really that useful for like
what is it really telling you
usually it's like oh i have
100 million rows representing tick level
data and i've got
a thousand or 10 000 tickers
the group i apply is going to apply that
udf on the scope of the number of groups
which likely will be small enough that
the penalty will be relatively low it's
not why you avoid group by apply you
avoid group by apply because then it's
going to stitch these things back
together and it's going to do an index
the line concatenation and anybody who's
ever used the concat function of pandas
knows this is dog slow stitching these
data frames back together
where you have to obey the index and you
have to keep the index in its you know
monotonic ordering can be very very slow
and if you've ever done concat somebody
probably told you drop the index concat
and then reconstitute the index kind of
like when you do bulk inserts in sql
and you end up end up being
significantly faster well
don't do apply because you're you're
forced to do that index-a-line
concatenation and that's going to be
very slow so you really really heavily
want a privilege that ag operations are
transform operations but there are
limitations to what you're able to do in
those operations simply because they
only operate on one column or one row at
a time
and so if i wanted to do my weighted
price
then the way i could do that is
uh
let's do it like this
i can take my trades
and i can add a
i can add a column to it and that column
is the total volume
and that total volume column
will tell me what the total volume is
up to that particular point
and no no that's that won't give me the
weight average price to get the weighted
average price what i want to do is i
want to actually compute the
that's going to be ugly
what i probably want to do is i want to
compute
the
volume
times the price
for each location
and then perform
the summation on that so i have to do
something to kind of set it up and so
usually you know decomposing something
that needs two columns into one is
usually figuring out how can i manually
rejoin these into a column so that every
operation is just performed in a single
column and so that's not actually that
interesting let's do the positions
because the position's a little bit
easier and that's where we're going to
go for the total volume
what we want to do is we want to figure
out what our position was at every point
in time not what our total position size
was at the end of this sequence but what
our position was as of each trade so
if we do something like this let me grab
one of these
and here
let me do an index slice because it's
date time and then this
so i'll just slice this to get all the
ones on this sticker fvci
whatever that happens to be
oh i already have that oh i already did
all my imports ahead of time that's good
there you go so i want to see okay i
went from 13 500 plus 49 600 so i went
up to 50 60 something thousand i want to
see what that is picking up and that's
actually fairly straightforward to do
and then i want to compute where i've
actually gone from a long position to a
short position so i can group these and
do something like a
buy price average buy price or average
sell price because what you can think is
if you're computing like an average
price of a bunch of different trades and
sometimes they're long positions and
sometimes your short positions well it
kind of makes a difference
you know so there's a spread right kind
of makes a difference which side of that
transaction you're on
uh
if you want to look at that average
price and so what you really want is not
just the mean price cuts everything you
want the mean price for all the buys and
the mean price for all the cells so you
have to identify what the position is
and identify which of these corresponded
to a by which these correspond to a cell
and so
what that means is we're going to do the
following
we're going to
[Music]
assign a new column into this thing and
it's going to be the total volume
and
this is what we were going for before
but when we compute the total volume
what we want to do is we want to make
sure that we only look at this one
ticker at a time because if we look at
these you know if we don't group up
these stickers in some fashion we're
going to get some very weird results
where the positions are going to
intermingle and because our indexing is
clearly about saying oh this is the date
but this also this partitioning of this
data set what we're going to do is we're
going to take this data frame we're
going to group by the ticker
we're going to grab the volume column
and
we're going to perform an operation
and the operation that we want to
perform here is actually fairly
straightforward we can do a cumulative
sum but i want to show you how we could
expand this a bit just so we can talk
about group by
the difference between group by
transform and group by ag
is group by transform preserves the
index
group by ag changes the index
when you group by ag you're aggregating
so the index is going to be whatever the
grouping criteria was if you group by
transform the operation will be
performed on whatever the grouping
criteria was
but
the index will stay unchanged this is
what i want i want the original data
frame to be
exactly how it looked like except i want
one more column on it and i want that
one more column to include my cumulative
sum so i could do this as you know a
simple cumulative something like this
or
i could do this as a transform
just to show you transform
where i transform each group
using an expanding
sum
and largely you know this just one one
of these will be a little bit shorter to
write but
they're basically the same idea and
let's just take a look at the first five
rows of this thing
so here you go and now i have my total
volume and let's actually look at this
just for one particular ticker just so
we can see if that actually worked and
you can see
this seems to work so it's computing
what my total volume is now that i know
what my total volume is i could compute
what
what what my what the sign of these
positions were so what i could do
is i could say
you know if i take
this data frame
and i take
this
total volume column
and i ask what the sign of this thing is
i can see is this a long position or a
short position so if it's one it's a
long position if it's negative one it's
a short position
not too hard
and once i've done that i can identify
the places where i've gone into a new
position because the places where i've
gone into a new position are the places
where it's crossed over the zero axis or
it's gone from being long to short or
from nothing to something and so my new
positions are fairly easy to compute on
this data frame i just
take that sign column
and i group it by ticker
or actually i like to do group by first
so let's do this first on the ticker and
then grab that sign column and then what
i can do is i can do a transform on that
time column because i want to keep the
same data frame i'm just creating a new
column so i want to keep the same
structure of this data frame i want the
same indexing i want everything to match
up
what i can do is i can look at that sign
and i can look at two values next to
each other and i can sum them and if
you've gone from long to short that sum
should be zero we've gone from short to
long from one to negative one sorry from
negative one to one that should be zero
any place where this is zero you've
actually crossed over the zero axis and
you have a new position
so
here we can now notate all the new
positions we have and we just have to
learn how to spell someday
there we go and so you can see those
aren't new positions there but if we
expand this a bit i wonder if we do
enough trades on this thing yep there
you go and you can see this was a new
position because we went from a long
volume to a short volume you can see the
sign changed and there once we know what
the long and the short positions are we
can use that in order to figure out what
the average buy price and the average
sale price are because it's just
an operation on this and so let's see if
we can do the let's actually go back and
do the weighted price
so we can do that against the
average price as i said the weighted
price here i want to do this and i want
to do this in a group by ag or a group
by transform i don't want to do this in
a group i apply just because it's going
to be slow so what i'll do is i'll
compute the weighted price first
and that's just a lambda df
and that's just as i said here we'll
pre-compute
the
volume
times the price
and
yeah so that should give us that and
then
our
weighted average price
is just
the
sum of those right because we're
and then we have to divide that don't we
so what we'll do is we'll compute the
weights first that'll make it that'll
make it easier
so we'll compute the weights and for the
weights what we'll do is we'll take the
data frame
and we'll group it by
each position in each oh here's where we
can actually use the positions so let's
compute the positions so we can figure
out what the weighted approach is per
position so we're going to back up one
more step so we can compute everything
correctly
what we want to do is you want to
compute
what the positions are
and to compute the positions
we're going to do this
we're going to take our
we're going to take our data frame
and we're going to group it by
the ticker we're going to look at that
new column and we're going to transform
it
and
we're going to compute
the cumulative sum of these because
this will give us what the position is
in terms of just a counting up number of
are you position zero one two three four
five because then we can group by that
if we group by that new
we'll get all the places where it's not
a new position in places where it is a
new position together which doesn't make
sense but if we cumulative sum down this
thing then you can see oh all of those
are position zero and all of those are
position one and then we can group these
in order to do
the
operation we want to do and we haven't
touched the single data plot group by to
apply it once we do that
we can compute our weights by doing the
following
we can say group by each ticker and each
position number
grab the volume from that
and transform that volume
by
taking the absolute value
of whatever the volume is and dividing
it by the sum so this gives us the
corresponding weights that's how we're
gonna have to do these weighted sums
yeah
and once we do that
then we can get the weighted price
pretty easily
because what we'll do is we'll just take
the volume or the weight times the price
so we'll first pre-compute what the
weights are there we go so that's our
weighted price and then to do our
average price
i mean we've already set this thing up
the way we want it to look
so
what we'll do is we'll say
group this thing
by the ticker
and the position
grab that weighted price
transform on that weighted price because
i want to preserve the indexing this is
the really key thing transform versus
versus
um
transform versus ack it's really about
do you want to preserve the indexing or
you want to change the index income and
there you go that's your weighted
average price
per position your weighted average price
on a per position basis so if you then
took this and
if we took this thing and we pivoted
into the columns
the value of that sign column we could
actually let's actually
do this down here
we took this thing and we took the sign
column
and the weighted price column
right
so here we have all of those we could
pivot that sign column into the columns
index
so sorry to pivot this
and
what that would give us
is
what the weighted price was for all the
long positions with the weighted prices
for all the short positions
and obviously here you know this is
giving us on the same indexing on the
same you know original indexing of the
first but you can see this is what the
weighted price is for each point in time
as a rolling
as a rolling average
your average buy price and average sale
price
and obviously what you want to do is you
want to do some backfilling or forward
filling on this so you know if you do
like a b fill
type thing
you know you'll get some back filling on
this just so that you can analyze this
later and look at the data and say okay
you know at any one point in time what's
my average buy price it's my average
sale price and so actually i want to
forward fill this because this is new
information coming in
and so here you can see
that's my you know
my knowledge of what the average price
the average sale price the average
brought the average weighted sale price
average weighted buy prices at every
point in time for a particular ticker
and
by virtue of how nicely all this index
alignment works this has actually been
computed on the entire data frame
simultaneously
so now i have
i have trade level data when i did the
trade on what ticker how much and i have
the actual
rolling weighted average buy price and
sell price for all of these and
looking at this there's one there's one
group by missing
because
these shouldn't be
these shouldn't match up here and there
so let's just uh oh cause a forward film
the ford fill isn't uh group eyewear so
here i'd have to do a group by
for fill
and because i'm going to preserve the
the indexing
i want
that so there you go
and so it's four so here clearly you
don't have enough information you know
on the longs on the on the long side of
this and
because i don't like that plus you know
i don't like these not nameable things
this is where i might want to rename
axis
and
we'll say this is what
short and long
axis equals columns
so we can actually
see what this thing
you can actually make heads or tails of
what this thing actually is
so
and i actually want to do this this
should be a uh rename
just rename access this is the one thing
that always trips me up rename axis
rename and which one of them changes the
values of the axis itself
otto is rename axis changes the axis
values i want a
set axis
that's what i want to do this is you
know the unfortunate thing about the
pandas api
all these names are so bizarre it's so
impossible to remember what's between
rename access and set access
as long as you know what you're trying
to accomplish
i feel i find that's way more valuable
than you know remembering is that rename
access or set access set access sets the
contents of the axis and rename access
changes the names of those axes so that
you can do index lined operations and
pandas can figure out how to line things
up
didn't say i was the expert i was just
saying that maybe if you put a little
bit of attention into the index maybe
you could be an expert one day too
i shouldn't say two maybe you could be
an expert one day and then show me how
to remember
how to do this without making so many
mistakes but any questions
any questions
it's a powerful tool then you do some
really fancy things that you just can't
do in numpy and
most of that comes down to what
index alignment
and operating on this is a
like index collection of two-dimensional
data or sorry one-dimensional data sets
and making sure that your your indices
are aligned and in the result you end up
with code which is very dense and
requires knowledge of the jargon of
pandas but for the most part
look this analysis very dense and
requires knowledge of you know
all the names of these different
arguments but if i had to do this in
pure python or if i do this in pure
numpy this would be 100 lines of code
and it would be incomprehensible it
would be so mechanical i would have no
ability to spot check it and say oh
that's definitely right
you know definitely this is dense but
it's dense because it's replacing
such an enormous amount of analytical
work that i would have to do by hand
myself
in
numpy in which case i would basically be
re-reconstituting the index or
recapitulating the index the sad thing
about indexing and index alignment
appendix is
if you don't use the index
you're going to end up creating your own
worst version of it as a column of your
data set and you're just going to
you're just going to try and do these
index line operations yourself in the
clumsiest
least efficient way possible
is no one convinced
by our
okay we have one person who's convinced
otherwise thank you all for joining me
if you have any questions tweet at me
take a look at the video and uh
see if you can maybe develop a little
bit of panda's expertise by
playing around with the idea of the
index thanks everybody